pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'en doutons plus l'été approche à
grands pas puisque voici que déjà sous
le soleil de la côte d'azur sont apparus
avec les maillots tropiques riz sans les
nouveaux uniformes sans lesquelles il
est bien impossible de concevoir des
occupations estivales digne de ce nom
c'est que le moment est venu de choisir
les formes les couleurs et les dessins
qui constitueront l'élégance sur les
plages dans l'été qui arrive car même
réduite au minimum
c'est encore d'élégance qu'il sèche
[Musique]
très peu de deux pièces qui apparaîtront
comme une survivance anachronique
on leur préférera cette année encore les
maillots d'une seule pièce avec une
prédilection certaine pour les
décolletés généreux dans le dos
[Musique]
m
et
avec cela beaucoup d'imprimés et du même
coup une variété infinie de coloris
voici donc comment nos modernes sirène
aborderont la mer cette année après la
longue vue d'un automne d'un hiver et
d'un printemps
[Musique]
tout le monde est rentré à washington où
il est arrivé pour annoncer la nouvelle
à faire du ce et 47 disparus en
allemagne orientale
le président eisenhower s'est vu
réserver un accueil de la population de
la capitale fédérale avait voulu
particulièrement chaleureux
pendant ce temps à berlin est aux côtés
de messieurs grosse vol et il briest le
président coach of n'allait pas jusqu'au
bout de sa menace pas de traité séparé
avant six mois
la conférence au sommet étaient bien
mortes pour l'histoire - senozan les
derniers soubresauts
par exemple cette conférence de presse
improvisée de monsieur khrouchtchev sur
le trottoir de l'ambassade soviétique
[Musique]
et à l'elysée la dernière réunion à
troyes où il n'était plus même question
d'atteindre le quatrième
la fin d'une conférence qui n'a jamais
pu commencer
mais bon
au terme de l'exercice sans atout qui
s'est déroulé c'est un jour durant entre
les côtes de provence et d'afrique du
nord
l'escadre française a fait escale à la
base stratégie de blizzard
[Musique]
bizerte n'était d'ailleurs nullement
l'objet de ce déploiement de force que
justifiée seulement la deuxième
croisière d'entraînement de la saison
croisière de trois semaines qui devait
ensuite offrir à l'escadre le spectacle
incomparable de la cité vénitienne
les marins avaient devant eux la
perspective de rester plusieurs jours à
l'encré
[Musique]
ce fut l'occasion pour eux de découvrir
le pont des soupirs et de musées sur la
célèbre place saint-marc cher à tous les
amoureux du monde au milieu de ses
habitués de toujours les pigeons
[Musique]
à cannes au milieu du ballet des
vedettes dernière l'après-saddam shelley
winters et ben johnson et des remous de
foule d'où émerge parfois un visage
célèbre le festival a connu sa plus
belle bousculade celle qu'a provoqué
maria callas
m
[Musique]
et il peut finir l'heure de la vérité
est arrivée une heure délicate pour le
jury qui en accordant la palme d'or à
federico fellini a provoqué un certain
mouvement de foule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'auteur de la dolce vita salue les
films soviétiques reçoivent le prix de
la meilleure participation laventure
d'antonioni et le film japonais kenji
reçoivent aussi un prix
[Musique]
et mélina mercouri et jeanne moreau se
partagent le prix d'interprétation
féminine
[Applaudissements]
hurd est pris également à paris mais
pour l'effort en littérature le jury du
prix fondé par eve de la croix qui
compte notamment le maréchal juin et
marie morgant a choisi de couronner
cette année un journaliste devenu
romancier jean lartéguy hockey élèves de
la croix a remis le chèque de 3000
nouveaux francs
[Musique]
toulouse à l'heure de la finale du
championnat de france de rugby 45000
spectateurs dans les tribunes et de
remarquable équipe sur le terrain lourd
de maillots font c'est qu'ils attaquent
et bézy nouvelle attaque par la
troisième ligne lourdaise le jeu est
rapide claire les deux équipes se
livrent à fond
et pourtant après 20 minutes de jeu bien
que le score soit de 6 à 3 pour les
lourdais nilo denis béziers non encore
marquer un seul essai le premier essai
lourdais ne va cependant pas tarder
domec numéro 8 relance on attaque sur la
gauche les trois quarts des bornes le
patron c'est un peu dur pour béziers qui
ne baisse pas les bras il est vrai que
la technique des lourdais est tout de
même supérieur leurs attaques sont
toujours fort dangereux
[Musique]
comme cette attaque d'ailleurs qui va se
terminer derrière les poteaux de béziers
essai transformé 14 à 3 à trente minutes
de la fin le match par est terminée
et bien pas tout à fait béziers contre
attaque très souvent comme en ce moment
c'est du très beau rugby de mouvement
mouvement perpétuel pour béziers qui se
traduit par un très bel essai du demi
d'ouverture 14 à 8
encore un petit effort trop tard c'est
finalement par quatorze ans que lourdes
on devient champion de france de rugby
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que la mer soit pour le portugal une
vocation historique on peut le voir dans
la tour de belem qui salua au xvième
siècle le retour de caravelle comme
aussi dans le nombre de ces fortins et
de serre doute qu'ils montent une garde
aujourd'hui strictement poétique le long
de la côte
on peut le constater pour aujourd'hui
dans l'activité portuaire de lisbonne
qui ouvre sur l'atlantique l'une des
plus belles rap du monde mais son trafic
annuel qu'illégale à marseille
le fait d'être le tout non par lequel
respire le portugal ne suffit pas à tout
expliquer la mer est beaucoup plus que
cela pour le portugal nourricière
d'abord car le poisson compose pour
toute la population la nourriture de
base et le spectacle des quais de
lisbonne avec leur marine à ce qu'ils
vont porter ensuite dans tous les
faubourgs les corbeilles plein de
poissons n'est pas seulement une touche
pittoresque mais l'expression profonde
et populaire de l'importance de la mère
de même pas un coin de côte qui
n'abritent un port de pêche et si naze
arrêt est le plus connu des touristes
ils sont nombreux ces villages à flanc
de rocher donc tous le jours les rues
vides ne s'anime que de l'éclat d'un jeu
de marelle
il
la mer là encore a mis son empreinte
tragique celle là les jours de tempête
sur la grève désert le long des barques
retirer dont certaines portent l'oeil
qui doit découvrir la proie au fond des
eaux des hommes perdus dans un songe où
le vent du large à sa part poursuivre le
grand dialogue ouvert entre le portugal
et l'océan depuis les jours au vasco de
gama regardait de cette place la mère
qu'il ouvrirait pour la première fois
jusqu'au 5
car ces hommes sont toujours les mêmes
ces visages d'aujourd'hui sont ceux
mêmes dont une aubaine salve s entourer
au 15e siècle la figure étonnante du
visionnaire que fut l'enfant enrique est
dont l'histoire a fait henri le
navigateur
à 25 ans il quitte à la cour pour se
retirer à sa graisse sur ce promontoire
désertique assailli par les vagues qui
marque la pointe extrême de l'europe
c'est là qu'il vécut 40 ans parmi les
astrologues les cartographes les
ingénieurs et les marins armand chaque
année de nouvelles caravelle sacrifiant
tout à cette passion qui ferait
découvrir la route des ânes
il ne connut pas son triomphe c'est
après sa mort que les navires de vasco
de gama franchir le cap des tempêtes
dont on a fait depuis le cap de bonne
espérance
de cette grandiose période reste deux
ton dos celui de vasco de gama le
découvreur et celui de camoens le poète
des découvertes sous les voûtes de
l'église de ieronymos il rappelle que
cette vocation océanides fille du
portugal
il y a quatre siècles l'une des
puissances maîtresse du monde et reste
aussi le signe étrange qu'on rencontre
partout la sphère armillaire
l'instrument des chercheurs de route
[Musique]